[Music]
[Applause]
as we make the segue to TJ watt who's
already won that award he has eight
sacks on the season 85 a half sacks in
his career just turned 29 I believe last
week good to have TJ back on the show if
I said you could have one Sack or eight
hurries in a game what would you take
I'll take the sack
yeah but that doesn't mean you had a
good game if you have one sack but eight
hurries doesn't that mean that you
probably had a better all-around game
yeah but it depends is it a sack fumble
is the sack demoralizing you know it's
it it all depends but uh at the end of
the day I think we're all trying to get
sags okay um you took your helmet off
and got
fined yeah that's
smart okay but you're not taunting like
you're just celebrating but do do you
even get a chance to say anything or is
it just hey you got fined they're going
to take it out of your paycheck no we're
we're going to try to appeal it and I
think that's just kind of like you said
it wasn't I wasn't trying to be
malicious I wasn't taunting at someone I
was just it was fourth down it was the
end of the game took my helmet off um I
understand there probably wasn't a whole
lot of safety risk because the game was
technically over at that point but uh I
mean I just have to be better I guess
okay but you have your loophole here
who's arguing your case
uh it's me and then my agency we handle
it you have lawyers in house that have
to go through a whole appeal process
section five article four line seven you
know all that
stuff uh have you been fine
before yes I have I've been fined a
couple times it's my seventh year um
I've had a good amount of I I like to
punch the football um so I've had a
couple of those I actually got one again
this past week for punching of the
football and then a couple roughing the
passers so I've been through the process
a few times do they take it out of your
paycheck or do you have to write a check
to the NFL home ownice no they they take
it out which makes it a little bit
better because then you don't have to
actually write the check right right in
front of you um how would you assess
this team so far and being in this
Division I mean it's a winnable division
but uh where do you guys stand sort of
in the hierarchy with uh the AFC North
yeah it's it's a tough division it's
always been a tough division since I've
been here I think we're uh we're happy
to be three and two and we know we could
better and we know that we haven't
played nearly close to our best football
yet and it's still so early in the
season but uh the buy came at a good
time I feel like we're going to get some
guys back and um we need to continue to
Spring some wins back to back uh is is
crucial here as my th always does why is
the Ravens matchup I mean it feels like
that's the best rivalry in football
right now it's just always so physical
uh when Coach T talks about that matchup
he always says like there's been rules
made around this game when it comes to
targeting and uh guys just big hits over
the middle Blind Side blocks it's just
always been so physical and um even
though the game has changed dramatically
over the last 10 or 20 years we've tried
and we I feel like we've done a good job
in that Riv of keeping an a clean but
also just continuing to keep that
aggression and uh there is there is a
form of hatred between Baltimore and
Pittsburgh and uh that's okay I'm fine
with it explain to me the punching of
the
football because I've seen where Max
Crosby punches the quarterback's arm um
is the NFL allowing you to punch the as
long as you hit the ball or or were you
yeah is I mean it's hard because the
ball's always close to the face mask so
it's like I'm never we're never trying
to punch the actual face mask because a
that would hurt our hand and B we know
it's a penalty but uh we're always
trying to punch at the football but what
people don't realize or some people
don't realize is that when a quarterback
has the ball or running back the moment
from here to here or here to here is a
split second so when I'm winding up to
go at the football it could be gone by
the time that I move so it's hard to
anticipate exactly where the football's
going to be and I think that's where you
get those um those spots where you're
hitting a guy where you're not
intentionally trying to you ever
apologize to a player you
hit oh yeah for sure I mean there's
times where your emotion gets the best
of you and after a play you kind of pop
a guy in the in the chin strap and
sorry let me calm down here for a second
my bad I real we still have to go a full
game I don't want to get a cheap shot
back my way has anybody apologized to
you after hitting you oh for sure I I
think at at the end of the day I mean we
never want to we never want to be
malicious I mean never want to be
disrespectful on the football field I
think both sides do a good job offense
defense of if someone does something
that they didn't intend to do or that
was a little dirty they're most likely
going to apologize and if they don't
that's where the problems ensue why
isn't roughing the passer
reviewable I don't know it's a good
question uh it's it's hard it's we do
everything we possibly can and uh I was
talking to the ref the other week that
you know when you go to tackle the
quarterback I'm rotating as hard as I
can I'm taking the hit because the
quarterback's landing on top of me um
but it's it's just the life that we live
and we have to adapt as much as possible
because those penalties are are massive
game-changing penalties they're 15 yards
in the first down yeah but they should
review them if we review basically every
play TJ when you think about it there's
time to review because that's what the
broadcasters do that if you have the New
York office look at these plays and then
say hey you know what that hit wasn't to
the face or you know as you said these
are gamechanging you know type of plays
here and it feels like I know they're
trying to protect the quarterback but
you know you got to help out the defense
just a little bit here and no rules are
to benefit the defense when's the last
time you had a rule that benefited the
defense well offensive holding helps me
from time to time which is nice but yeah
it's it's one of those things that's
obviously way about my pay grade we just
try to adapt to the rules that are in
place and um try to play as clean and
smart as possible okay why are they
letting the tackles line up a little bit
further back off the line against you
guys that's that's something we're we're
tackling to and the the refs are getting
better at it uh the thing is that if a
tackle Line's a little deeper they're
going to be more lenient on letting us
take that credit card alignment or
getting as close to the line of
scrimmage as possible so it's kind of an
in-game thing um hopefully if he's
lining up a little deeper they're not
giving him that two clicks of the remote
Head Start that uh whatever they call it
um it feels like it's an advantage
because the offensive linemen haven't
kept up athletically with the edge
rushers so they almost they're calling
shots yes I am absolutely here's another
thing that they're calling offensive
lineman downfield like these bubble
screens it feels like these linemen get
out there but they are calling that it
feels like a little bit more it seems
like a point of emphasis
here yeah I mean I I mean I would like
to think they're trying to call
everything and I understand there's a
whole lot going on and I don't know if
they have enough bodies to really see
everything I mean like we always say you
could call a holding on every single
play it's just a matter of what they're
able to see in what's not going to slow
the game down but what if I said
offensive linemen have to wear mittens
incredible that they can't hold you
would be awesome I think you'd see a lot
more a lot more pass rush wins across
the
league uh now that JJ's retired is he
getting a little
doughy no he is not let himself no no
that's that's the thing is like he'll
send a meal of like a big cheap meal of
pancakes and waffles and everything and
then later in the day he's like all I
can eat is fruit and like grilled
chicken breast I'm like why I mean
there's no point you don't have a game
tomorrow like just indulge man enjoy it
for a couple months but uh he likes
staying in shape did you ask him to join
the
Steelers no I mean that's not that's
another one of those things that's not
it's way above my pay grade I I don't
have any say and who we bring in well
you could you could did you ask him if
he wanted play I didn't drop it in
suggestion box uh no I never blatantly
asked Jade if he wanted to come and play
um I think his career took its course
and my career is on my course and uh
they never were able to meet his son
looks like he's six years old he's
massive I
know he's massive I I would be uh
somebody's gonna give him a scholarship
here soon I know he he uh they're coming
out here in a couple weeks and I hope
he's saving his first steps when he
comes out here it's funny JD always
sends videos of him like pushing
suitcases and call like Prowler pushes
and he's in training already all right
let's play the uh max bench
press for TJ so one rep max bench press
yeah hold on now all right so max bench
press one rep best ever oh ever ever I'm
not saying now I'm saying ever for TJ
Todd I'm gonna start with you 4:30
4:30
Satan
uh 415 all right
Marvin one rep 525 ho
damn
Oham this is TJ here not JJ yeah ex
Paulie I'm gonna go one rep
465 I'm gonna go one
rep
385 it was 425 at one point but we don't
touch we don't touch that anymore it's
no no point in risking it these days
who's the strongest guy you ever been
around oh James Harrison I think I mean
oh God guys throwing weights around like
crazy he still is he still is it's
incredible the guy is doesn't age it
seems like he could probably use him for
a couple of plays man he is he is one
big dude hey uh congratulations where is
the defensive player of the year uh
trophy uh back home Wisconsin yeah keep
it back home so if I walk into your
place in Pittsburgh do I have any idea
you play
football uh no not unless you go in the
office I don't like to have stuff all
over the house
yeah but you could have like a statue
out front or something like that that
would be JJ has a statue out front his
place yeah if he did he'd hear about it
for
sure that would not be acceptable hey
great to talk to you congrats uh thanks
for joining us thank you very much see
you guys that's TJ wat next game will be
at the Rams uh week six by then they got
the Rams coming up just turned 29 years
of age